[Musique]
bon soit bien vivant qu'est ce que votre
magazine culturel heures au menu ce soir
jean-louis poitevin signe un ouvrage
consacré au sculpteur installé à
elancourt nicolas sanhes une géométrie
incident titre du livre est nicholas
année l'invitée de ces démissions à
l'occasion des journées européennes de
l'artisanat d'art nous nous sommes
partis pendant la rencontre d'un art
particulier le trompe l'oeil et puis
dans sa chronique à nicolas gervais nous
emmène à la rencontre des films qui
seront en concert le percutant le 11
avril au prisme à elancourt voilà ce que
vous pouvez découvrir dans ce nouveau
numéro de casque
[Musique]
nicolas sanhes bonsoir vous oubliez vous
travaillez à saint quentin en yvelines
dans un atelier en cours un livre vous
est consacré s'appelle la géométrie
incidente il est signé jean louis
poidevin la première question est lancée
c'est quoi la géométrie ainsi donc non
on va penser à un descente mais non ces
incidents elle était passée à descendre
mon trajet en métro c'est un peu c'est
pour le résumer en quelques mots c'est
vrai c'est compliqué parce quand même
300 pages de peau leur ouïe pour en
parler mais en gros c'est une façon
d'aborder la géométrie classique et de
se dire que si on regarde donc la
géométrie on sait que lille est faite de
points et si on considère que ce rousset
en change cette idée propre cette
géométrie
ils sont se dit que finalement ça peut
être aussi un vertical et horizontal et
bien ça change tout ça crée une
incidence et c'est tout l'objet du livre
qui explique ce petit détail qui est dû
à une observation du travail et tous les
jours y est intervenu plusieurs livres
qui vous ont été consacrés pas
directement vous êtes d'autres artistes
mais là cette premier league qui vous
est vraiment consacré commencé a fait le
travail avec les enfants
alors il ya eu des catalogues déjà
personnel mais ça c'est vraiment le dire
aux beaux-arts
si justement liens du un contre sur un
programme libre pour un catalogue
d'ailleurs d'expositions collectives
dans le nord donc vous avez raison et
c'est comme ça qu'on s'est rencontré il
avait écrit surmonter déjà sur mon
travail et on a imaginé à ce moment là
de faire de tout ça vous pouvez la
réflexion et c'est comme ça que c'est
parti c'est plaisant cdc c'est un bel
ouvrage ça fait sa marque sa marque un
moment dans la vie de tous cas ma
carrière puis ça fait trente ans que je
travaille bon voilà donc c'est sa marque
une période et j'espère que l'on ouvre
une autre vous êtes tannés à rodez ça
s'entend votre accent et vous dites que
vous venez du même pays que pierre
soulages le peintre un graveur de
l'abstrait était surtout connu pour son
utilisation
alors il m'a inspiré
oui non d'inspirer part ça il m'inspire
toujours d'ailleurs ce que lorsque l'on
s'est rencontré ou annulation du musée
soulagés à rodez d'ailleurs je profite
de citer le nom de benoît decron qu'a
écrit la préface du musée du catalogue
pardon oui ils m'inspirent parce que
c'est un homme d'une grande rigueur
intellectuelle dans le travail il a une
certaine vision de la rigueur absolue ce
qui est la création et j'essaie de
m'inspirer oui après sur un peu
artistique
il ya eu une période lorsque j'étais
étudiant j'ai travaillé sur des rameaux
de chrome noir qui ce qui est son cas
était différent de sa culture mais
j'étais plus être intéressé par des
artistes marc rennard tout kilic sont
des peintres américains
vous êtes diplômé de l'école des beaux
arts de carrière vous avez dit de
travailler depuis 30 ans vous êtes
installés sur le territoire de saint
quentin depuis plus d'une quinzaine
d'années
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie d'être
au sculpteur justement parce que parce
que sur la peinture c'est compliqué
lorsqu'on a des gens comme ça comme
soudage mais parce que simplement ce jeu
parce que je suis en quelqu'un qui suit
du monde
d'abord de la terre juin je suis plutôt
j'aime sorte relationnel à la matière
mais c'est aussi est le résultat d'un
processus de travail d'étudiant qui m'a
amené vers la sculpture
vous dites aussi à la sculpture est un
art démocratique mais dans la cité
puisque vous faites des sculptures qu'on
peut voir dans la ville notamment à la
trappe
oui dans le sens où elle est partagée et
que tout le monde est propriétaire de de
cette oeuvre parce que et tout le monde
que cela se l'accaparer appartient à
tout le monde parce que c'est de
l'argent souvent le public et qui fait
pour ça donc du coup j'ai vu un policier
l'a alors vous avez bien toucher la
matière le corps d'amélia tous et
l'acier parce que vos oeuvres sont en
acier alors pourquoi l'acier parce que
c'est malléable parce que c'est ça
permet de faire des pièces importantes
et permet de mesurer toute la halle à la
pratique de la sculpture dans le sens
des récents développements et ça me
laissait et financier c'est un matériau
qui est très proche de l'étrier utiliser
la figure en contemporaine mais j'ai
commencé par que ses deux boys que je
suis arrivé ici à cet endroit
après ça c'est un processus a fait le
livre explique souvent le processus qui
fait partie de ces pièces de bois vert
vers ces lignes dassier qui sont
aujourd'hui le fondement du travail là
parmi toutes les sculptures que vous
monumental puisque vous êtes spécialisé
sculpture monumentale que vous avez
réalisé il y en a eu une récente celle
pour la ville de valenciennes c'était
une culture qui est à peu près 7 m 2 sur
5 mètres de large
quand une ville comme valenciennes par
exemple vous passez commande comment
vous travaillez vous réaliser des
croquis
ou c'est une décision commune avec les
services culturels d'une commune de la
ville ou c'est non non non lorsque la
ville de 28,2 me demander de taille 7
sur ce projet d'abord il me demande de
choisir l'espace dans lequel je voulais
que ma ceinture ce soit soit installé
c'est à dire que vous êtes allé dans la
vie ce qui me paraît aussi est ce que tu
deviens adjoint à la culture à l'époque
m'a accueilli à l'ancienne a fait
visiter toutes les luttes contre 8
heures les commandes publiques et des
médias nationaux des artistes et il m'a
demandé de choisir en espace et je
choisis la place cardon à valenciennes
qui est une enquête une place proche du
musée proche du jardin public et j'ai
fait donc la chine me dis je vais
travailler sur un projet choix d'oeuvres
d'art vodafone ans après je suis revenu
avec avec un projet précis sur la maison
spirel et lieu disons que le travail de
sculpture de la signalisation et travail
de l'atelier
mais bien sûr que tu es le compte de
l'espace de quel aspect tueur la tête et
il faut imaginer l'oeuvre en fonction de
cet espace qui fait 80 il est trop petit
il faut que le public puisse l
appréhender sur ses quatre côtés
voilà donc c'était un travail qui à la
fois rallye l'espace urbain et de trois
ateliers
la particularité de ces sculptures c'est
qu'elles sont elles sont lourdes
évidemment là en l'occurrence pour
valenciennes je vois qu'il ya trois
pièces d'aci qui font chacune une tonne
est à la fois quand on les voit poser ça
fait léger convenu comme un nuage da sur
la machine enfin la magie comment vous
travaillez justement pour obtenir cet
effet à la fois on sent que sont
l'impression que c'est tout léger et
quand on l'a on voit les images de la
pause et l'installation de la sculpture
on voit que c'est quand même du boulot
ou quoi c'est long comment vous arrivez
à faire ce côté un peu léger et
techniquement plus c'est compliqué parce
qu'elle repose sur pas grand-chose à
trois points trois points là bas
non c'est en fait la parité montreuil
c'est que je aussi je fais les
structures sont suspendus dans l'atelier
alors suspendu avec les avec des grues
donc ça en fait la structure elle est
peintre
contrairement à celle par exemple d'un
avenir qui me saoule turquie par du sol
et qui c'est qui tord pour faire à ces
lignes d'acier moi je construis mes
sculptures par éléments ensuite je
rassemble dans l'espace et je la pose
quasiment réaliser un espace et donc
c'est une autre façon de penser la
sculpture et de penser le rapport
physique de la sculpture il ya ensuite
il faut que je tienne le ciel situé jure
qu'il est très technique
parce que ça tient ligne tels que sur
des petits accrocs l'espace d'accrocher
mans et l'importance des lignes fait qu'
il a fallu résoudre les problèmes
techniques qui doit il ya les entrailles
d'un générique et derrière on est
sculpteur on est artiste on est aussi
mathématicien et oui comme vous aimez
que les gens apprécient vos oeuvres
qu'elle peut-être plus beau compliment
que vous faire un visiteur ou un
spectateur on observateurs comme un
compliment qu'on peut faire à nicolas
sanhes quand on vois je sais pas
je vais simplement que les gens sont
heureux de dur avec eux autour d'une
sculpture et que la structure peut
changer leur religion leur espace et les
amène vers un moment de réflexion et de
poésie voilà ça me fait plaisir
je reviens sur scène c'est vraiment un
nouvel aboutissement puisque c'est
vraiment un vrai livre qui vous et qui
vous est consacré effectivement vous
avez vous travaillé depuis longtemps
fait vous avez jamais arrêté de
travailler
non jamais j'ai 2 en 2h02 envie
d'enseigner ccc pas grand chose ça veut
dire quoi y as et un style nicholson est
forcément vous pas que nicolas sale avec
l'équipe est en tout cas oui mais
vraiment il commença qui commencent à
paraître oui oui oui mais après le temps
est encore long après il faut donner le
temps à l'art c'est une question de du
temps il faut tenir
après on verra après je cours pas après
je cours je travaille tous les jours
pour faire plaisir et puis c'est de
mettre en place une véritable réflexion
sur la culture et montrer un processus
une démarche ici que eux qui tout à fait
autre que notre profession que vous avez
des procès en cours alors si les
expositions à lille sur la sorte parce
que vous êtes notamment soutenu par la
fondation des treilles 5 et 6 appareils
dans le 20e arrondissement et des
projets aussi pour d'autres communes
alors cette année chez cache pas ses
positions et ses sept étés quoi manger
une exposition donc enfin un soldat
trice voilà tout l'été une grosse
exposition au château sainte roseline
mais ses sculptures mines tél c'est
juste à côté la fondation devenait je
fais partie des châteaux des ajustements
des grains plus parce que devenait
bernar venet il est aussi adepte des
sculptures monumentales
oui créneau pas tout à fait ils sont
deux pincées différentes mais il lui
s'intéresse aussi à beaucoup la
mathématique
alors j'espère que je vais pouvoir le
voir si tu étais un bar alors bernar
venet a été et est venu dans les
yvelines à versailles puisqu'il avait
exposés dans les jardins du château de
versailles ça va ça fait rêver nicolas
sanhes j'étais jeune oui mais voilà ça
va nous garder sa maison
ça vous fait rêver d'exposer à
versailles château versailles je sais
pas mais vivre de grands moments comme
ça oui oui c'est plaisant une exposition
au niveau des jambes qui si un jour des
gens qui font la propulsion jour là ça
peut-être saison c'est un trait le jeudi
2 avril donc demain vous serez au
restaurant des templiers l encours tout
près de votre atelier d'ailleurs quand
une séance de dédicaces avec jean-louis
pots-de-vin merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être une sur pato de cause
merci beaucoup vous connaissez le trompe
l'oeil vous aimez danser c'est pas du
tout votre style c'est pas mon style
mais c'est assez c'est assez sur quoi
justement on va poursuivre ce magazine
en parlant de avec une autre forme d'art
donc le trompe-l'oeil une école de décor
mural existe à versailles à l'occasion
des journées européennes des métiers
d'art les étudiants sont venus présenter
leur savoir faire
ces motifs fleuris ce sont des
grotesques l'art du trompe-l'oeil
proposé aux regards des visiteurs du
château de versailles là sont en train
de réaliser des panneaux décoratifs
d'inspiration 18e qui sont qu'on appelle
les grotesques et voilà qui
leur demande d'avoir une forme de
dextérité dans le maniement du pinceau
dans le don de gestes sont des ornements
qui ont pour caractéristique justement
que d'être adapté au pinceau c'est le
sait de pinceau qui fait la forme des
bretaye sq du faux marbres ici au
château de versailles le trompe l'oeil a
toute sa place son est même presque
l'essence de lui certes on a du vrai
marbre on a de la vraie pierre on l'a
des boiseries magnifique mais on a aussi
du trompe l'oeil
ce soit du bois que ce soit des bas
reliefs
ce soit du faux marbre il ya des
trompe-l'oeil qui sont uniquement
décoratif et d'autres qui poussent
jusqu'à être vraiment illusionniste
toute la peinture classique il ya une
notion de trompe l'oeil qui existe
là il ya des cages d'escaliers
entièrement fausse moulures et beaucoup
de faux marbres ici
un peu partout mais les aubrais marque
d'ailleurs on a parfois du mal à
distinguer j'aime bien tout les
imitations d'être de faux donné
l'impression de en fait et c'est quelque
chose qui est très intéressant et très
très bluffant en fait aussi l'école
d'art mural de versailles avait toute sa
raison d'être ici au château une façon
aussi de faire connaître l'établissement
installé dans le quartier notre dame une
structure qui accueille peu d'élèves une
vingtaine seulement par session et à
l'issue de la formation d'une année 100
% travailleurs sûr de trouver un emploi
c'était là un français d'abord dé quoi
je pense c'est sa renommée dans le monde
qui pour la raison en est quand même à
versailles pour essayer de parler des 7
cette activité il ya une vraie demande
pour cette activité même par des
entreprises internationales alors les
élèves ont travaillé pour les
entreprises un qui se trouve à paris
comme également ils sont maintenant
demander de d'autres pays comme en
russie comme on
en chine est maintenant à dubai le
trompe l'oeil à savoir faire dont on
retrouve des traces dès le xvème siècle
un art qui se développe en france au
xviiie siècle un vrai style de précision
et du détail
[Musique]
deux dates à retenir pour le jeune
public dans votre agenda ce samedi à la
médiathèque 17 mar à elancourt c'est une
séance de contes pour les tout petits
qui est proposée parents et enfants sont
invités à venir partager des histoires
et des comptines et c'est gratuit
et toujours pour le jeune public cette
fois dès l'âge de 2 ans une pièce de
théâtre papa est en bas mais vous
connaissez la suite qui fait du chocolat
une pièce de théâtre autour de deux
poules en chocolat bah c'est pas que
l'une et blanche l'autre et noir c'est à
découvrir ce samedi à 11 heures à la
ferme de bel ébat de guyancourt tarifs à
partir de 3 euros
nous allons poursuivre ce que c'est avec
une page musique et nous on musical
plutôt musique donc ou plutôt une mue
renouveau musical avec les phillies mon
qui le ramena ce sont les percussions
ils seront sur la scène du prisme à
elancourt le 11 avril et nicolas gervais
les a rencontrés attention c'est
percutant bio de batteur déjanté il eût
elle plus de riz avec dextérité à toute
épreuve et elles seront le 11 avril au
prisme pour l'heure inconnues bellagio
voici les classements qui dans le
kiosque attention humour percutant et
oui moi aussi je fais la batterie les
semaines tous ont fait moins mal qu'elle
essaie d'acheter saoudienne tu m'entends
alors tu m'entends ouais je t'entends ça
marche dans les deux sens sont des
règlements qui ne veut pas dire grand
chose ces deux scènes une association de
mots entre monkey sage on voit le
spectacle on se fait un peu une idée des
deux singes qui a sur scène et fise
c'est un mot qu'on retrouve sur les
partitions de batterie
c'est un mot qui en général écrit à la
fin des mesures et qui signifie un peu
la liberté ont fait un fils un roulement
remplissage brevet des collèges mais si
on veut insuffisant
rail brevet des collèges dernier exemple
ou que j'ai eu c'est pareil c'est ça
j'ai mon permis de vols argent c'est
vrai oui j'ai eu mon permis
j'ai mon bafa musique enfin bon un bar à
musique spécialité musique
[Musique]
moi j'ai commencé la batterie à l'âge de
11 ans dans une école ou mamie on m'a
mis dans une école de batterie mon père
était un petit peu musicien
voilà j'ai commencé à 11 ans et j'ai
jamais arrêter là j'ai fait un truc
s'appelait l'école agostini c'est bon tu
as fini alors mon père était était très
musiciens de finale à wimbledon papa et
musiciens oui parce que mon père a tout
fait pour faire tomber leurs musiciens
de ton père ça c'est parce qu'il était
professionnel à elle était prof de
batterie
donc en fait j'ai eu des cours
gratuitement à la maison ouais bah ouais
ouais bah moi je peux vous en apprendra
ghosting
[Musique]
c'est à la baisse des prix de lyon et on
avait pour mission de faire une
démonstration de batterie pour une
marque de cymbales qui nous endort ça à
l'époque et on s'est retrouvés tous les
deux à jouer voilà avec chacun une
caisse claire en disant allez on doit
faire quelque chose d'un peu
démonstratif pour les batteurs qui
viennent nous voir mais on avait dès le
début on a envie de faire quelque chose
d'un petit peu fun on s'est mis dans un
local c'est vrai qu'au bout d'un quart
d'heure on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait le même bagage technique même si
j'étais déjà bien meilleur que lui à
l'agréable ou là mais on avait le même
bagage technique et puis on se
comprenait à musicalement on se
comprenait humainement c'est tout de
suite compris des rencontres comme ça
qu'ils font et puis après dans l'humour
on sait on s'est vite rendu compte qu'on
avait envie de faire passer un peu la
pilule de la pilule du duo de batteries
pas par le biais des mois
[Musique]
en 2010 on rencontre notre producteur
claude françois junior qui dit vous
devriez travailler avec un metteur en
scène ça vous aidera vraiment et là on a
rencontré gilles galliot et qui a
démonté totalement notre spectacle
garder tous les objets et la remontée
dans un autre sens nous a aidés à
vraiment franchir un palier sur le bas
pour que ça devienne quelque chose de
lisse ses deux grues mauriste en scène
c'est vraiment on aime à dire que on
parle de langage universel qui sont donc
comme tu l'as dit le rythme et l'humour
c'est un spectacle d'une heure et quart
à peu près qui est fait autour de la
batterie autour du rythme mais qui est
absolument pas au final une
démonstration de batterie
[Musique]
on parle pas un seul mot de français
pendant le spectacle en gros c'est un
spectacle qu'on a écrit sans le savoir
pour un petit peu la planète entière
talât le beijing j'étais assez on a joué
là bas pour une émission de télé pour le
nouvel an chinois ans a trouvé au milieu
d'eux entre steve hay hélène de hélène
et les garçons une grosse james blunt un
espèce de troupes de chez pas combien de
danseurs de tango fin c'était et on
savait pas qu'il fallait jouer
[Musique]
l'idée c'est patent de montrer aux gens
qu'on sait jongler avec des balles de
tennis sur une batterie ou bien qu'on
s'est joués
l'idée c'est de le faire et que ça ait
l'air facile et que ce soit toujours au
service de l'humour effectivement on a
commencé à se creuser la dette en dix
ans mais avec quoi on pourrait jouer sur
une batterie
donc voilà on a commencé à me lancer des
jeux sur internet en demandant aux
internautes de nous dire avec qu est ce
que vous croyez qu'on pouvait jouer on a
essayé des quantités de choses on a jeté
des quantités de choses a effectivement
on a quand même gardé sur scène dès des
raquettes des raquettes de tennis de pin
pon des baguettes géante faite dans des
tringles à rideaux
on joue avec avec nos mains avec des
nunchakus avec des balles de tennis
plein de choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a griffonné un tout un tas d'idées on
a des voitures batteries sous le coude
qu'on avait fait pour le gala de l'union
ouais franchement pas ce moment où tu
commences à faire la faire que le monde
devient un rythme tout donné il ya
vraiment un champ d'expérimentation qui
est qui et qui est très large
[Musique]
voilà et après les fils qui on retrouve
celle qui a une batterie de bons plans
au culturel kathryn hâle un tout autre
style pour continuer notre date d'agenda
avec les 12e rencontres de l'harmonie de
saint quentin en yvelines un concert où
seront rassemblés plus de 80 musiciens
pour un programme autour de musiques de
films et de variété c'est ce samedi à
l'auditorium de l'école de musique de
trappes c'est gratuit avec une libre
participation aux frais
[Musique]
comme tous les mercredis vous propose de
retrouver la chronique cinéphiles on
démarre avec les avides de spectateurs
ce mercredi au micro de ma tin de
capvern
je les trouvais un peu pâteux en soit
l'adaptation est plutôt bonne pour avoir
lu le roman voit les décors et les
costumes la reconstitution est vraiment
impeccable et mais en soit le scénario
fonctionne bien et pour ceux qui aiment
ce qui tourne autour de la seconde
guerre mondiale sont satisfaits ah oui
un très très bon moment vraiment
exceptionnel c'est vraiment exceptionnel
c'est vraiment un film a recommandé les
actualise acteurs formidables formidable
emma de caunes on la voit pas assez et
très très bonne actrice ils sont tous
très très bien traitée très émouvant
très émouvant ah oui je vais recommander
autour de moi oui très intéressant et
puis la condition de vie de ces temps là
c'était triste pour les gens qui
devaient subir les patrons c'est surtout
moi sur la condition de la femme
sama ça m'a fait rappeler un peu les
romans de jane austen soit les femmes
est obligé de se marier soit les objets
dessus bien et nous poursuivons avec le
coup de coeur de cette semaine ce soir
gaël pineau du grenier à sel de trappes
bonjour cette semaine au cinéma le
grenier à sel nous participons au
festival cinéma du réel qui est
organisée par la bibliothèque du centre
pompidou à paris
c'est un festival international de films
documentaires
nous recevons
le réalisateur du film ancré qui
s'appelle à rachid djaïdani son film est
présenté dans le festival dans le cadre
de la sélection française et rachid
djaïdani il a réalisé en 2012 le film le
film rengaine et il revient là avec un
portrait d'un artiste un peintre
contemporain qui s'appelle yaz et on le
voit pendant le film on le voit donc
c'est un documentaire c'est la vraie vie
on voit réellement se faire se fâcher
avec sa galerie à paris se retrouvait
sans galerie donc plus aucun moyen de
montrer ses oeuvres les vendent ou de
vivre et il va galérer il va on va le
voir en période de création donc c'est
assez c'est assez joli à voir c'était
sympa à assister à cette création
et ensuite on va le voir aussi
rechercher une galerie est donc ce n'est
pas une surprise c'est pas un secret je
peux le dire quasiment la fin du film il
va finir dans une galerie à new york qui
n'était pas encore ouvert qu'il va
falloir qu'ils goûtent le projet de
toutes pièces et a donc c'est une énorme
aventure qui on va suivre pendant une
heure et quart avec avec le réalisateur
et peut-être y associe qui sera
peut-être là ce sera donc vendredi 3
avril à 20h45
l'entrée est libre sur réservation vous
retrouver tout ça sur notre site
internet www.cineagde.com à bientôt
merci c'est la fin cette édition merci
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
mercredi prochain bonne soirée
[Musique]